today we heard the news report that
coca-cola Pepsi derp changing their
recipe for their soft drinks and the
reason for that is that for me thalam
adult and to me college soul have been
found to be in those drinks and very
small quantities and they pose some
cancer risk
it would take around about thousand cans
a day to get you to that alarming level
but nonetheless they want to be safe
right so it's for my fellow Mendes also
this is the molecular model that that
we've got here here's the methyl group
is it the four position in the
imidazoles is this five membered ring
here we've got two nitrogens and the
rest of carbons it's been found in rats
and mice not humans to potentially cause
cancer and so just to be safe they want
to change their process and actually
comes from the coloring so coke dr.
pepper they're brown that coloring comes
from caramel also called caramel
coloring and what you do when you make
caramels you take a sugar this is
glucose they tend to use dextrose which
is a bit more complicated and they heat
it up and to get a deeper color you can
add things are ammonium salts and
sulfide salts and that gets a much more
intense brown color but it's actually
the ammonia which is a nitrogen based
species it's nh3 it reacts with the the
sugars as they degrade and that's what
forms the four methyl amid result and
two methyl images all so you don't need
to add the ammonia you get a less
intense color but it means it's safe
you've just got the the normal sugar
byproducts in the caramel and the
coloring and then you find absolutely
fine so I suspect that's exactly what
coca-cola pepsi-cola are going to be
doing well it'll be the same color but
because the color intensity will be less
with the UH the non ammonia added
processed caramel they'll have to add a
bit more of that coloring in a course
that will cost them all because of to
make more of it but it's safer and so
the coke I'm sure will be exactly the
same colour caramel coloring has no
flavour associated it's literally just
there to give it that colour and so I
would imagine that there will be no
taste difference whatsoever what is that
is that what is it in nature is that
like is it just something you make for
coca-cola and Pepsi or is it you know is
it yeah just by a nice question so for
my fellow midges oh is a byproduct of
this
coloring of the manufacturer of this
coloring compound but in nature we find
versions of this material so if I if I
put this little group on here now this
material is histidine that's a naturally
occurring amino acid and it's very
related if I remove this this group here
this carboxylic acid group that's
histamine and of course everyone's heard
of antihistamines histamine itself as a
neurotransmitter
so imidazoles themselves aren't
particularly a problem but this for
methyl images all here has been found in
rats and mice to be a cancer suspects
agent in of course these these companies
want to be absolutely sure that their
products don't contain anything
associated with cancer and so just to be
safe they're removing it well I am they
removing it because they'll have to put
anti-cancer warnings on their labels
well yeah and of course I don't want to
have anti-cancer our warnings on the
labels although you would need to drink
a lot a thousand or more cans of soft
drink a day in order to attain the
levels where you're at that danger level
we didn't have at the University of
Nottingham a sample of for me fellow
midges oh but this is the parent
compound so this is a midges all so if
we take this if we remove the methyl
that is a midges ol and imidazoles
used an awful lot bass because it's a
really good catalyst and base and it's a
nice solid white compound as you can see
here for me fellow midsole looks
essentially the same it's a slightly
more yellowy color than a midsole which
looks almost pure white
do you drink any of these soft drinks I
do yeah the it's a nice drink
not everyday but I will drink coke I'll
drink dr. pepper
I'll drink Pepsi I'll drink lemonade and
beer and wine and other things too
absolutely
but not a thousand cans a day I wouldn't
drink a thousand cans of anything today
absolutely and I suggest that our
viewers don't either Cheers